- Hi everyone, welcome to
today's Homeroom live stream.
Today we will do an ask me
anything, which is always fun,
I enjoy it a lot.
Before we dive into the questions,
although I encourage you to
start thinking of questions
and putting them in the message boards
on Facebook, or YouTube, or
wherever you're watching this,
we have team members who will
help surface these to me,
but literally ask anything,
and I also ask team members,
surface whatever shows up,
even some of the less
traditional questions.
But before we break into it,
I will give my standard announcement
reminding folks that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
That means that no one owns Khan Academy,
I don't own Khan Academy,
or you own as much of
Khan Academy as I do,
and we can only exist because
of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about donating.
I also wanna give special thanks
to several organizations that
have supported Khan Academy,
pre-COVID, but especially when they saw
that we were running at a
deficit going into the crisis,
and our costs were going
up because of server costs,
and new programs, and
courses we wanted to create.
Special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, and Novartis,
who helped us close the gap,
although we're still running at a deficit,
and donations of all
sizes make a difference.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy.
So with that, I'm eager
to take your questions
about literally anything.
And yeah, ask me about anything.
And I don't have questions in yet,
so I'll just start talking
about random stuff.
I was looking at that
little starting screen
for the live stream,
and it reminded me about how
bad my current haircut is.
Not that my previous haircut was good,
but several people have
asked in the past about this,
this haircut was done with a
clipper, in about 80 seconds.
The SpaceX launch was about to happen,
I didn't wanna miss it,
I was in my back yard,
so I took the clipper from my wife,
who is a more accomplished
barber than I am,
that's not what she does by training,
she's a rheumatologist,
but that's how I got this haircut.
I know none of you have asked about that,
but I do feel self-conscious about that.
So let's see, from YouTube, Eliot H says,
"What do you think about lack
of privacy on the internet?
We saw abuse of power in
George Floyd's murder,
do you worry that data collected
by GGL," I guess, Google,
"and Facebook will be used
to hurt people someday?"
Wow, that's a very big question, Eliot.
I don't know.
And, you know, regardless of what
your point of view is on data privacy,
kinda the genie might be out
of the bottle regardless.
We have a world now where
everyone's got cell phones,
everyone can do live streams,
everyone can records something and put it
immediately on the internet.
Now, for the most part,
we're seeing examples
of that being used for good.
We're seeing examples of that
being able to document things
that we've heard about,
but when you see it, you just realize
how horrific it could be,
like George Floyd's murder,
or what happened with the
birdwatcher in Central Park.
And those are just two of
the more recent examples,
this is happening almost
on a daily basis now,
and that is creating more
transparency, more accountability,
and that'll probably
drive better behavior,
because, in the past, people who wanted
to get away with something would say,
"Well, you know, no one's gonna notice,"
but now, it might be
someone with a cell phone
who's able to document it,
it might be a security camera, you know,
that's on the light post
that's able to document it,
and so you're a little
bit more conscientious
about what might get seen or not seen.
So that element seems good, but then,
of course, there's another side to it,
which is, you know, the argument,
there's always been this tension
between security and observation,
and then privacy, and liberty,
because you could imagine an
Orwellian government one day
using that to control
who interacts with whom,
or track where you move, and all of that.
And that could be a very scary thing.
And, there's also, not even talking about
an Orwellian state,
there's worlds where, you know,
you're a young person,
you're in high school,
you're in college, I've
heard young people sometimes
don't do the most
high-judgment activities.
I might have been guilty
of some of that myself,
and it's not helpful if you're
doing something kinda silly,
dancing with your friends in a silly way,
and it gets documented, and
shows up on social media,
and then you lose all control of it,
and then you've lost your privacy
and your ability to kind of just,
even if it's something fairly harmless,
but if an employer sees you
dancing in that really silly way
that might might not be a good thing.
So, yeah, it's a tough, tough situation.
I think, as individual citizens,
all I can do, is all you
young people out there,
be careful of folks recording you,
be careful of your privacy.
You might wanna post a bunch of stuff,
because it'll kinda make
your friends giggle,
and this and that,
but it can have very
far-reaching consequences.
You know, there's definitely
examples of adults
with careers, big careers,
who've made some stupid
tweets or social media posts.
Now, for society it might've been good,
because we realized what was
really going on in their mind,
and we realized that we
probably don't want them
to be the people entertaining us,
or the people who have that power,
but you could imagine, you know,
maybe for some of these people, they said,
"Wow, I made that really dumb tweet,
and now it ruined my career."
And I think, you know,
that's something for everyone
to be a little bit thoughtful about,
because it can get so easy
to just kind of be unfiltered
in those types of settings.
So anyway, I don't know.
It's a hard thing that we're all
gonna have to struggle with together,
but I get a sense that
the genie's already out of the bottle.
Everyone's got phones,
everyone's got recording devices,
they can post it onto social media.
I'm even afraid of this
whole world of deep fakes
that is becoming more and more possible,
where you literally could
construct a video of someone,
even if they weren't in the video.
Which is cool, because you get to see
Princess Leia in the new Star Wars,
but it can be scary in
a lot of other things.
So let's see.
From YouTube, Orchid
Blossom, I like that name.
"Why does school seem more
like memorization testing
than learning fun and useful things?"
That's a good question, Orchid.
So, I think there's two aspects about it.
There's the aspect that you control,
which is your mindset, that
you take towards school,
and then there's the thing that, I guess,
all of us collectively can control,
but it's more of a systems change thing,
which is how does school
itself present information,
or guide you through that information.
So, I'll start on what
you, yourself can focus on.
I found that even if
you are in a curriculum
that is very focused on memorization,
or what seems like
random steps of process.
It seems like, how do
you solve this equation,
and it's not going to the intuition,
there is always some underlying intuition.
And what I would encourage you,
and I've said this before
in the live stream,
is remember, this material,
even though it might seem like
something delivered to you
in a very dry, or disjointed,
or memorization way,
it usually is saying something
very profound about the universe,
even if it's fact knowledge,
that fact knowledge is
usually quite useful.
And so what I would say is remind yourself
that it might not taste so good right now,
but it's telling you something
deep about the universe.
Ponder it even if the curriculum you're in
isn't drawing the connections, ponder it.
Take some time, indulge,
think about how that thing
connects to other things in the universe.
And you know, that's
definitely the attitude
that I took growing up,
and I did just because, I don't know,
maybe that's just how
I thought about things.
And you know, for sure, I
used to sit in some classrooms
that felt a little bit
not the most engaging,
and then I had other classrooms
that were incredibly engaging,
and the teacher really
drew the connections,
and inspired us, and made us appreciate
how beautiful what was
being learned really is.
But when you have that attitude
that regardless of which
classroom you're in,
you're always gonna ponder
it, draw connections,
try to work through it yourself,
then it'll all be interesting,
and it won't feel like memorization.
You will actually retain much,
much more of that material.
Now on the other side, what
can the system do different?
This is where we at Khan Academy,
we are trying our best,
and obviously, we are far from perfect,
there is a curriculum out there,
there are standards out there,
and smart people can have a hearty debate
about what should be in
and what should be out.
But I think what we try
to do at Khan Academy
is try to present it to you in a way
that one, you can get as
much practice and feedback
and confidence in the
material as possible,
but also have fun doing it.
And it could be fun because
of the game mechanics,
and what's known as extrinsic motivators
that have nothing to do with the content,
but that's just motivating you to do it,
but hopefully, it's also
fun in the work itself.
Hopefully, when you're doing
the exercises on Khan Academy,
you're like, "Oh! I'm
kind of enjoying this."
And many of you all have
watched videos on Khan Academy,
and you'll see, I usually am having fun
working through the material,
and hopefully that is infectious to you,
and hopefully, when you see the videos,
and if it's me, or one of our
other content team creators,
you see we're modeling for you
that really is interesting,
this really is intuitive,
this really is telling
you something profound
about the universe,
or introducing you to
a new way of thinking.
So, we're gonna try to do our best.
I think many educators are also very aware
of what you're alluding to,
and so I've seen educators, more and more,
doing their best to really
bring the intuition,
the interactivity, the human
side, the interesting side,
because the subjects
inherently are interesting.
You almost have to work
to make them boring.
So hopefully that happens over time,
and you see more and more experiences
that are more engaging
and less rote memorization, or boring.
Let's see, this is from
YouTube, Fuzzy Space,
I like that username as well.
"Hi Sal, I teach math,
and one of the things
I'm struggling to do is
write digital exercises
for students that assess as proofs.
Have you guys at Khan Academy
come up with an ideas on how to do this?"
Fuzzy Space, you are
asking a very big question
that we at Khan Academy
have struggled with
for many, many years, and
we've tried to do our best.
You know, for those watching
who don't know what a math proof is,
some of you might remember those kinda
two-column proofs in geometry,
and when you took it, it might have seemed
like some random things
to the previous question.
But a proof, at it's essence,
is can you start with
some basic assumptions about the universe,
which we call our axioms,
things we just assume,
and that from those axioms,
you know, one of the axioms is, I exist,
I just assume I exist.
It's kinda hard to prove or disprove.
I think, therefore I am, whatever,
but it's an axiom that I exist.
But from basic axioms, can you build,
can you deduce other
truths about the universe,
assuming that those axioms are true?
And that's really one of the
powers of real mathematics.
You know, Abraham Lincoln famously,
intimately learned all
of Euclid's elements,
which is what modern geometry is based on,
and even though we're talking about
something that's 2000 years old,
because he realized it made him
a much more rigorous thinker,
and made him a better lawyer,
and made him a better debater.
And so that's what proofs is all about,
just for those of you all who
aren't math-y, so to speak.
What's hard about proofs is,
it's inherently a creative process.
Whenever people say, like,
"Oh, well you can do math this way,
but creative subjects
you have to do that way,"
and I say, "Well, no, math
is very creative as well."
If you talk to any mathematician,
they're coming up with
new and novel proofs
that no one has ever thought about,
new ways of deducing some
truth about the universe.
And ideally we could build that skill
in as many students as possible,
even if they don't become mathematicians,
they, like Abraham Lincoln,
it will improve their
critical thinking skills,
and their ability to think rigorously
about what is for sure true,
what might be true but is not proven,
and what is for sure not true,
or what might not be true,
but we haven't proven it yet.
The hard thing about anything like that
is it's, you know, multiple choice,
or in a free-response type of format,
we at Khan Academy, which is,
it's hard to make that auto-gradable,
or provide auto feedback.
We do attempt to do this
in many of the standards
by, you know, we'll have an exercise
where there's a proof with multiple steps,
and the user has to pick
whether the proof is correct,
and if it isn't correct,
what step was the logical fallacy made in.
So I think that's one area, you know,
we have a couple of things
where you can drag and drop rationales,
especially in geometry,
for why a particular
statement could be right,
and then what could be the
next statement after that.
But to your point, it's
very, very, very hard.
I think, you know, the ideal is,
it would be similar to
what you'd do in writing.
I mean, there are some AIs
that can grade writing now,
in fact, we use it with our SAT work.
Maybe you can do something
like that with proofs.
I've heard of some projects,
I'm not intimately aware of any of them.
I also think there could be something
around peer review that does it,
where, imagine you're asked to prove
some statement in mathematics,
and someone who's already proven it,
and has been validated that has proven it,
maybe it's an older student,
or maybe it's just another
student in the classroom,
can then look at your proof,
and grade and give you feedback
as to whether it is correct or not.
That's an interesting mechanism
that could happen inside the classroom.
I'm also intrigued about ways
that we could do that in
the broader world as well.
So, from Facebook, Guillermo Acosta says,
"How do we know your child is ready
to begin on Khan Academy?"
Great question.
Sorry, I'm having some
internal burps, I guess.
How do you know if your child
is ready for Khan Academy?
So I think there's two major
Khan Academy experiences,
one is Khan Academy kids,
and then there is kind of our website,
which also has an app, and
is available on mobile.
So Khan Academy kids is
designed for ages two to seven.
It covers all of the Headstart
and Common Core standards
for pre-K, Kindergarten, and first grade
in math, reading, writing,
and social/emotional learning.
And so, if you have someone,
especially between ages two and six,
who is kind of at their
developmental level,
I highly recommend Khan Academy Kids.
It's highly interactive,
it's tablet or phone based,
so kids don't have to
know how to use a mouse,
or a keyboard, or read
directions and all that.
I would say our core Khan
Academy, or big Khan Academy,
whatever you wanna call about it,
I think, for third grade
and up, it is very usable.
The reason why I say third grade
is because Khan Academy does presuppose,
if you're using it online, on the web,
it presumes some use of the
mouse, and the keyboard.
And even if you're using
it on a mobile device,
even if you're using the app,
it does require some, enter the equation,
or it says stuff like
"Select all that apply,"
and to a kindergartner,
select all that apply,
they might not even be able to read that.
Or even a first grader.
So, I say third grade for sure
is where we've seen a lot of,
and there's definitely examples
of fairly precocious kindergartners,
and first graders, and second graders
who have high reading capability,
who are also able to engage
on kind of big Khan Academy, so to speak,
starting with our early learning work.
Because our content goes all
the way into early learning.
I would say if you have a student,
a child that's kind of right at the cusp,
Khan Academy Kids, the
first grade content's
feeling a little bit too easy for them,
so they're ready to
start going into second
and third grade content on
big Khan Academy, so to speak,
I would recommend for you,
as a parent or loved one or sibling,
to be able to sit down with that student.
And don't give them the answers,
don't tell them how to solve it,
but explain to them when it
says select all that apply.
Or if they're having trouble
moving something with a mouse,
or their motor skills aren't
where they need to be,
that you can help them there.
And just also motivate them,
because the game mechanics,
or the motivational mechanics
on the big Khan Academy are not, you know,
100% designed for the six
or seven year old crowd.
So I think having a loved
one next to the child,
working through it,
I think that's great for
Khan Academy Kids as well,
but it's especially important
for the younger students
on kind of our non-Khan
Academy Kids Khan Academy.
We have to come up with a better
word for big Khan Academy.
Let's see, Facebook, Kieran Dudlany says,
"Would love to know Sal's thoughts
on how to get more girls
interested in STEM subjects,
especially math."
It's a great question, Kieran,
and I won't claim that
I'm the expert here,
but, you know, I have
anecdotal experience.
Many of you know that Khan Academy started
with me tutoring my, at the
time, 12 year old cousin Nadia.
And, in a lot of ways,
what she was going through
was what I think a lot
of girls go through.
She was 12 years old,
she was a good student,
she was trying to do what's right,
but she had kind of convinced herself
that she wasn't a math person.
And I don't know where it came from,
I'm guessing it probably
got from, you know,
you'll hear your mother say
that you're not into math,
or people gravitate
to, or they see a movie
where they disproportionately see
that the man's the math guy,
and the woman's the humanities person,
and so they build these
internal biases on who they are.
And I do think it's around
11, or 12, or 13 year olds
that all of us start
really defining who we are,
what are we, quote,
good at, or not good at.
And obviously, that's not
a good attitude to have,
because that's not a growth mindset.
You should say, "I can
be good at anything,
and I can only discover that by failing
and pushing myself out
of my comfort zone."
But Nadia was there, and
I remember, back in 2004,
it took a couple of weeks
for me to just deprogram
this self-perception of her
that she just wasn't good at math,
and that was the biggest hurdle,
because once I kinda deprogrammed that,
she was off to the races.
This was a young girl in seventh grade
who was put into kind
of a slower math track,
after I deprogrammed that,
or helped deprogram it,
and got her caught up, and
even ahead of her class,
within a year and a half
she was taking calculus.
So clearly, she was very capable,
this is as a freshman in high school,
she was very capable at learning math,
as I think all children, and all girls,
are very capable.
So, I think it's a combination of,
you have to have someone
who truly believes it,
not just giving them kind of lip service,
truly believes that not
only are they capable,
they should be capable.
I also think it takes the time,
and that kind of habit-forming, of,
let's call it 20, 30 minutes day,
of seeing that if you do that practice,
and Khan Academy's here for that,
but if you do that 20, 30 minutes a day,
no matter where you start,
within a month, two months,
you're going to see real gains.
And likely, you would have caught up
or even surpassed where your class is.
And I should think, you know,
I've gotten in to pedagogical debates
about whether it's good to
go ahead of class or not,
but I do think for a
student's self-confidence,
if you're a seventh grader
who thought you weren't good at math,
I saw it with Nadia, if you can get ahead
of where your class is,
you know, I remember that first time
that I taught Nadia kind
of an algebra topic,
and she picked it up quite fast.
You know, simple solving equations,
and I said, "You know,
Nadia, what I just did
isn't seventh grade, it's
not even eighth grade,
it's actually a ninth
grade algebra topic."
And I remember, still, you know,
kind of her, I could hear in her voice,
we we're actually doing it over the phone,
but I could kind of hear her
eyes light up over the phone,
that like, "Really? I, Nadia,
have just done ninth grade math?
Maybe I'm a math person!"
So I think that could be a fun thing,
is, don't make everything
just about catching up,
or the next test,
start introducing a few
ideas that are further out.
You know, with my own kids,
there's ideas from calculus
you could introduce.
The idea of limit, you could introduce,
actually, to very young kids,
ideas of solving equations, you know.
I talk about this with my
nine year old daughter,
and she gets it.
And when I tell her that actually,
this is kind of a ninth grade concept,
she's like, "Oh, maybe I'm good at this."
And I think that's the kind of
thing that could be helpful.
So, yeah, that's my best advice,
but I'm definitely not an expert there.
So, from Facebook, Syme Hur-Hassan says,
"Hi Sal, what are your views
on the new policy for
international students?"
So I think wat Syme is
referring to is this policy,
and I only read some of the headlines,
or I read some of the
articles fairly quickly,
but what I read was this notion that,
if a student is not attending college,
an international student
is not physically attending the campus,
that they will not get a
student visa to attend.
I think that's a bad idea,
because it then makes the
schools not think about
what's right from a
healthcare point of view,
and then, if they say, "Okay,
I guess we're going to have to
figure out some way for
the kids to be on campus,
because otherwise they're
going to have to leave."
And so, you know, any time you're creating
a kind of a conflict of
interest, in any space,
that does not have a clear benefit to it,
I don't get the benefit
of something like this.
So, yeah, that's my view on it.
And when you issue an edict
that will disrupt many people's lives,
and maybe even put them
in some type of danger
because there's a pandemic going around,
or even puts professors in danger,
not even just the international students,
puts the community in danger,
puts the whole country, you know,
because anyone gets coronavirus,
they now become a vector
and spread it to others,
so that's not a good thing.
So, that doesn't make sense.
And if you're gonna do
something disruptive like that,
it should have a benefit,
and it's not clear to
me what the benefit is
of sending international students home,
or not allowing them to be here
while taking things distance learning
if that's what the universities
think is most appropriate.
So, yeah, you can imagine,
you're a sophomore at
the local university,
you're an international student,
you're on a student visa,
and for very good reasons,
epidemiological reasons,
the university has just decided
that it's best for the fall
to do everything online,
and so you're like, "Yeah, I'll do that,
I'll stay in my rented house
that I'm sharing with other
friends, other students,
and take that course,
and now, all of a sudden,
I'm hearing that I'm
not allowed to do that,
I will have to leave the country,"
which might have all
sorts of implications.
Some of it is, it's even
hard to travel right now.
But anyway, that's my
answer to that question.
So, from YouTube, Adarsh Prasana says,
"Is it very hard being a not-for-profit?"
On some levels, yes, although I think,
to do anything in any way, shape, or form
at scale can be hard,
and there's always going
to be competing interests.
If you're for-profit,
you have to raise money,
get investors, hire up,
et cetera, et cetera,
and then, the really hard thing is,
in some ways, for-profit, it
might be easier to raise money,
because you can appeal to people's,
"Hey, I have an idea that
can make you rich," you know,
"Give me a million dollars
and I'll give you 10% of my company,
and when this becomes
a $10 billion company,
that million will be a billion,"
and people kinda, "Ooh, that's
exciting, here's the money."
The hard part about for-profits, though,
is because of that motive,
when you wanna do something that you think
is sometimes just the
right moral thing to do,
or it's consistent with your values,
but if it's not consistent,
what maybe some of those investors
think should be your priority,
or what they think is going
to maximize their profit,
that can sometimes, and you know,
most investors, I think,
are very good people,
and they wanna do the right
thing, et cetera, et cetera,
but the mindset is, look, we're
here to optimize our profit,
we're not here to be, like,
do-gooders, so to speak.
Now, ideally they could do both,
but that's where it can lead to tensions.
Not-for-profits kinda have the
symmetric opposite problem,
where, everyone knows that like,
the not-for-profit's very clear,
there's no owners here,
this is our mission,
we're here to do good in
whatever dimension do good is,
for Khan Academy, it's
free world-class education
for anyone, anywhere, you know,
give access to materials,
especially to students
who otherwise would not have them,
try to move the dial in
efficacy in learning,
support teachers, things like that.
So the good thing is, when
people donate to Khan Academy,
they know that's what they're donating to.
We have a board of directors
that holds us accountable,
it's made up of many of our larger donors,
but also just experts in
education, and educators.
And what I love about our board meetings
is that they don't say, I
mean, we don't have a profit,
in that nation, but they're saying,
"Sal, we need to make sure
that these philanthropic funds
are reaching the kids that need it most,
we need to be able to measure efficacy,
how do we engage kids who
otherwise would not be engaged,"
that's the conversation, which I love,
because it's super-aligned
with the mission.
The hard part is, is that, you know,
you gotta raise money continuously.
There are revenue streams we've developed
that are consistent with our goals,
folks like the College Board pay us
to do a free SAT practice, so that helps.
We have corporate sponsors,
but for the most part, you know,
as you saw at the beginning of this,
I ask a lot of people
for money all the time,
and you know, you gotta kinda
check your ego at the door
when you're asking for money from people.
But you know, there's
positives to that too.
I think when people donate it
brings them into the mission,
they become ambassadors for
the work that you're doing,
and you know, one of the
fears of not-for-profit is,
we also, obviously,
don't give people stock,
the way, if you work at
a Google or Facebook,
you get a nice salary, but then actually,
most of your compensation
comes through stock,
especially if the stock is appreciating.
Well, whatever your salary
is, you might get two, three,
some times five, 10x
of that through stock.
And we live, you know,
Khan Academy is competing
in certain areas of the same talent pool.
We have educators, and content
creators, and researchers,
but we also hire a lot
of engineers, designers,
and product managers,
and we directly compete
with the Googles and
Facebooks of the world.
And there was a fear
that we would not be able
to attract the same talent
because we can't give stock,
because there is no such thing
as stock in Khan Academy.
The good thing is, we have
been able to attract talent,
which just shows you
that really great people,
if you pay them enough
so that they can live
and send their kids to
school, and college,
and go on vacations,
and eat at a restaurant
every now and then,
that they actually care
more about mission,
intellectually challenging work,
and being able to work with
other really impressive
mission-aligned people,
so we're seeing that.
So anyway, I believe anyone
running an organization
that's a not-for-profit or for-profit
at the scale of the Khan Academy
with the reach of a Khan Academy
wouldn't feel relaxed all the time,
but to you're point,
there's definitely struggles
of a not-for-profit.
You know, my dream is that Khan Academy
is an institution that lasts forever,
that maybe one day there's an endowment
so that it can last for hundreds of years,
and billions of people,
because I think the social
return on investment
is definitely there, so, fingers crossed.
So, from Facebook, and time goes by fast,
every time I do this,
I didn't realize we only
have a few minutes left.
Well, I can go a little bit longer,
there's a lot of really
good questions here.
From Facebook, Robert
Haggen, or Hagen, says,
"Do you recommend daily
lessons during summer break?
While I want my son to
enjoy his summer break,
I also know options for summer fun
are limited during social distancing."
So, my view, and I'm a
self-described tiger-cousin
for my family, that's
how Khan Academy started,
and I have three kids
now, I would say yes.
And, this doesn't mean ruining
your son's summer vacation,
it means 30 minutes a day of math,
maybe 30 minutes a day of reading,
and maybe 30 minutes a day of writing,
journaling, whatever that is.
And I think if you did
that, and, talk to your son,
there's nothing, I just
described an hour and a half
of a very long day where
the sun sets very late,
and there's plenty of time
for doing other things,
and playing outside,
and all the things that we
know and love about summer.
But if he's able to do that,
not only will his skills not atrophy,
but he's likely to go
into next school year,
and it goes back to that
confidence question,
whether you're a boy or a girl,
just being more confident,
have a bigger margin of safety,
probably perceive him or her self
more as an academic person who's
capable of learning things.
So I would absolutely go for it.
And once again, you don't
have to go overboard,
it doesn't have to be
hours and hours a day.
It can literally be, you know, worst case,
do half an hour of math a
day, half an hour of reading.
Like, that's not a lot.
So, if your son is watching,
I think if your dad asks you to do that,
that is very, very
reasonable of him (laughs).
So, let's see, we're almost out of time,
so I just want to...
"Does Khan Academy use
adaptive learning technology
that's from Imani Malaika?
To some degree, we've used it,
and we're trying to do more adaptive.
I could talk to for a
long time about that,
but I'll go to the next question.
From YouTube, Vramya Sivikanth,
"Do you have more than
the Khan Academy website?"
Well, there's the website,
there's the mobile app,
and also, the website,
there's also mobile web,
we have Khan Academy kids.
Separate from that, I've mentioned
a couple of times on this forum,
there's a bit of a side
project that I have
called schoolhouse.world,
which is a very early
stage, volunteer-driven,
non-Khan Academy project, but related,
where it's pairing up students
who need help, live help.
Let's say you're on Khan
Academy, you're learning,
you're getting practice,
feedback, you're watching videos,
but you still want live help,
you can go to schoolhouse.world,
right now it's focused on
high school mathematics,
and then there's volunteer tutors
who are running group tutoring sessions
to give folks that live help.
So that's another interesting thing
that's at a very, very early stage.
Let's see, from Facebook, Jackie Tate,
"What is the best math skills to get ready
for computer science
section of Khan Academy?"
Well, it's interesting,
the computer science,
the programming section of Khan Academy,
you really don't need
to know a lot of math.
I would say, if you get to kind of
a fifth or sixth grade
level of arithmetic,
yeah, if you know your negative numbers,
you're pretty well-versed
with decimals, fractions,
exponents, I think you're pretty close
to being able to engage
on our programming.
It was literally designed
for elementary school,
kind of late elementary
school students, in that mind.
If you have kind of am
middle school level,
or especially even early algebra,
where you're starting to
understand what a variable is,
then I think you're in
very, very, very good shape.
But a lot of ways, you
doing the programming
is a great way to learn what variable is
for a lot of students.
VX Lee is asking a very
flattering question,
"How are you so smart?"
My ego is flattered by that,
but I will tell you that
there's many times in life
that I have and continue
to feel not-so-smart.
So, everyone feels impostor
syndrome sometimes,
everyone feels out of
their element sometimes.
But I've been able to probably build
more confidence than most in,
let's call it academic
or intellectual pursuits,
because, to the very first question,
I've always been someone to ponder,
and try to draw connections,
and when something just
doesn't make sense,
I haven't been afraid to ask
what some people would
call dumb questions,
and I found that oftentimes,
what you think are dumb questions,
when you really dig in, and
double click and ask someone,
they oftentimes can be profound questions,
and that can make you
build your confidence.
So I would say, it's all about
creating a habit of learning,
a habit of being curious.
Keep asking questions, don't be afraid
to show your vulnerability,
and fill in those gaps,
because before you know it,
you're gonna be a
polymath that knows a lot
about a lot of subjects.
And, you know, let's see,
Mohammed Sami Mussaid from YouTube
asks a similar, "How can you get yourself
to start liking school?"
Look, in most of human history,
we have just never had the luxury
of investing in
understanding the universe.
Most of human history, we
were running away from things
or chasing down things for a meal,
or worried about wars with
the neighboring tribe,
or something like that,
and so it's actually an incredible luxury
for us to have something,
and I think it's a necessity,
but compared to most of human history,
it would have seemed like a luxury
to be able to have a time of your life
where you could invest, and learn,
and develop your critical thinking.
And I know it's not
always the most engaging,
and sometimes it can feel
a little bit demoralizing,
but when you realize that
you're getting to learn
human knowledge that had been built up
over thousands of years,
that Newton, Marie Curie,
the kings of antiquity would have killed,
they probably literally would have killed,
to learn the knowledge
that you get to learn
over the course of your schooling,
and to realize, that, you know,
don't put it all on other people
to make it interesting for you.
Don't put it all on other people
to kinda spoon-feed the knowledge to you.
This is all about you really owning it,
and kinda owning the hill,
I'm using a skiing analogy,
because I'm not a great skier,
but that kind of was an unlocking for me,
where it was just like,
don't be afraid of the hill,
own the hill, this is your hill.
I'm still a horrible skier,
but have that same mindset
when you're learning something.
Don't put it on the teachers,
like, "Hey, teacher, make
this interesting for me,
otherwise I'm gonna check out."
That's not fair to the teacher,
because you say, "Hey,
I'm gonna put it on myself
to make it interesting."
And there's more resources than ever.
You have you're textbooks,
you have your incredible teachers,
but you also have resources
like Khan Academy.
You know if you wanna know
why something is useful,
things like, on YouTube now,
there's someone who's made a video
about pretty much everything
on an enrichment side of things.
So, you know, the world's your oyster,
it's really for you to make
it what you wanna make of it.
So, with that, I realize
I'm way over time.
I have a lot of fun doing
these ask me anythings.
I think we might be
doing it again tomorrow?
Worst case Monday?
But either way, I look forward
to continuing our conversation,
so thank you everyone for joining today.